Hans Kim addressed the backlash fell
online after defeating Rick Diaz to
maintain his regular spot on Kil Tony at
the New Year's Eve arena show the newest
inductee to the kill Tony Hall of Fame
David Lucas asked Hans directly about
the hate online to which Hans said this
I think those jokes are fine I don't
know if they were the best I think that
they could be received in a better light
I don't think that it was as one-sided
as Reddit thinks it is I think they're
counting out a lot of what I was doing I
don't think that they're giving me a
fair shot I don't think it was that
blowout where Rick did that great cuz he
didn't do that great either Brian Redban
also chimed in on the controversial
decision during a live stream where he
said that in that exact moment on stage
it felt like Rick had won damn Rick has
this I think and then when they went to
Shane and Matt they both said Rick got
it I think probably everyone agreed that
was on stage including Hans I haven't
asked Hans that but